hi everyone i'm delighted to welcome you
all to our monthly inference colloquium
series
this series as many of you know is one
of the flagship events of our larger
interdisciplinary project that examines
the nature of inference focusing
specifically on issues of correlation
and causation across disciplines
it is a very ambitious interdisciplinary
project and i'm delighted that our
speaker today is one of our core members
of of this team
and this project is supported by the
john templeton foundation as well as uh
yale's frankie program uh in science the
humanities
um and i think these epistemic issues
that are sort of front and center in
most academic disciplines today
and in particular as we all move into
sort of the big data era in our
respective disciplines
the question of
how we can infer and produce new
reliable knowledge
using new tools and techniques is
really a very critical one to explore
right now
i am really excited about today's
speaker dr sarah teitman
and her unique take and perspective from
the vantage point of molecular biology
but first
i would like to thank our benefactors mr
and mrs richard and barbara frankie for
their generous support of the frankie
program and other um efforts many other
efforts actually at yale
uh that bridge disciplines
and i just wanted to take this moment to
remind all of you assemble that we are
recording this event and that all
participants must therefore mute their
videos
if you wish you can
as is customary submit your questions
through the chat feature
and you can feel free to submit your
questions um we will actually have a
dedicated q a session at the end of the
talk
so it is my real honor and privilege to
introduce our speaker today uh dr sarah
tychmann who is the head of cellular the
cellular genetics program at the welcome
sanger institute in cambridge england
and it is also a particular personal
pleasure because she's one of my close
friends
and we have known each other through the
early stages of our scientific careers
sarah tykman's research focus has been
on understanding sort of global
principles of regulation regulation and
gene expression and protein complexes
with a particular focus on issues of
immunity
she earned her doctorate at the mrc lab
of molecular biology in cambridge and
was a bite memorial fellow at ucl
she started her own group at the mrc
laboratory of molecular biology in 2001
and was also an elected fellow of
trinity college cambridge
um she her lab focuses on discovering
stereotypical pathways of assembly and
evolution of protein complexes um
in 2013
she moved to the welcome genome campus
in hingston cambridge jointly with the
european bioinformatics institute and
the welcome sanger institute
and in february 2016 she's had an
incredibly illustrious career already
and has so many prizes so many honors
and i'm just going to cherry pick a
handful of them because i really don't
want to take up any more time
and i'm
dying to hear what she has to say so in
2016 um she became the head of the
cellular genetics program uh at the
sanger institute and co-founded this
very very exciting initiative called the
human cell atlas international
initiative which he continues to lead
sarah is an elected member of mbo a
fellow of the academy of medical
sciences and a fellow of the royal
society
so
without further ado
sarah we are absolutely delighted to
have you speak in the series and really
look forward to today's talk and the
discussion that is going to follow
tomorrow
so uh before i hand it over to you i'll
just mention that our discussion for
tomorrow is professor neil lawrence who
is the deep mind professor of machine
learning at the university of cambridge
so um please join us
at 3 p.m edt tomorrow for a continuation
of today's exciting session
so sarah thank you so much korea for
that uh kind introduction and very
generous
um invitation for me to speak at this
exciting interdisciplinary colloquium
it's an incredible opportunity to sort
of reflect on the field of
computation and theory in molecular
biology and i'm i'm really um excited to
be giving this talk
so i've called it the inference of
nature because what we're inferring in
computational biology
theoretical biology bioinformatics
is um
[Music]
are our molecules
uh and
and cellular components
of organisms and and their interactions
and so it's um
essentially prediction of features of
nature kind of at that level of the the
individual components
and within theoretical and computational
biology
at this molecular level
um
they are there
the one of the main aims is of course to
predict
causation from correlation
and there are really two different
schools of thought here one is that that
you want to get the mechanistic details
right so if molecule a interacts with
molecule b interacts with molecule c
and causes a
um a pathway or cascade of biological
interactions and processes
then you want to be sure that you're
that you're modeling the sequence in the
the correct way and and the feed forward
and feedback loops and and and
individual interactions and the the
directions of these arrows all
precisely correct and ideally with
quantitative
uh
kinetics and so on attached to the as
labels to these interactions
and so
even though a may correlate with with c
you'd want to make sure that the the
modeling is is modeling the correct
sequence of a to b to c
and not sort of jumping ahead of itself
and and this school of of theoretical
and computational biology this school of
modeling is is really concerned with
these mechanistic details and um
describing them with differential
equations and all sorts of
you know boolean models and related
methods
um that sort of fit into that that
that level of biology but um
there's there's another school of
thought that's really more concerned
with correlation
rather than
those those mechanistic details and and
for a very good reason
and that is that um
uh you know we can we can calculate
linear non-linear um
all different you know
correlations in in any numbers of
dimensions shown here is a very simple
correlation between a and b
and often we're doing that not between
sort of two simple molecules and a few
data points but in absolutely huge data
sets and and the data sets that i'm
showing here are actually quite modest
on the scale of what's available
to biology um in in this day and age
if in in for many different types of
measurements and the field that i'm most
active at the moment is genomics and
functional genomics where we're
measuring
for instance as an example the the mrna
levels the expression levels of of all
the genes in the genome in millions of
cells at the same time and so the the
size of these data sets are absolutely
huge and we can calculate the
relationships between or the
the correlations and relationships
between individual genes and represent
them as these networks for instance
that's one way of of mining data we can
also
collapse high dimensional data that's in
20 000 dimensions into a two-dimensional
space and what's shown here on the
right-hand side are individual cells and
you can see how there are there are
hundreds of thousands of them projected
into this little
uh this little panel on the right-hand
side here where i'm showing my right
cursor and so the the the way we the
only way to really tackle these data
sets is using statistical and
computational tools from data science
as well as machine learning and
artificial you know more globally
artificial intelligence methods deep
learning and so on because the magnitude
of the data is simply so enormous that
we can't it doesn't make sense to tackle
it with with differential equation based
systems in mechanistic models and and
what we're extracting are correlations
if you will
um
in these very large data sets in order
to extract principles
of um the molecules their interactions
um on the right hand side it's actually
molecular fingerprints of cells
so it's it's um basically features of
these biological building blocks
from from large data and and really what
i'm trying to say is that
um
you know the the the correlation
really or these relationships in this
data space
are are informative and sometimes we
don't we don't really care whether they
are
causal or not it's just the correlation
is enough to make a prediction and so
that what i'm trying to say is for
instance
um red sky at night shepard's light red
sky in the morning shepard's warning
that little ditty about the weather and
that you can predict the weather from
the the color of the sky
is you know it's a very powerful
uh
predictive principle
but of course the color at night doesn't
cause the weather the next day but the
correlation is good enough to be very
powerful and that that in itself
sometimes sometimes predictions in and
of themselves
are are really what we care about even
if we don't understand
the the the um
[Music]
the detailed mechanistic reasons um we
haven't deciphered every single
causal
you know element in the process
so sarah if i may ask for a quick
clarification
in this sort of multi highly
multi-dimensional spaces yeah that is
predicated on the fact that you know all
the variables in question right you know
what the variables are
or is there an element of also looking
for what might be potential and i ask
only because it's such a huge
multi-dimensional space so it's a great
question i think um you know this comes
back to the sort of
let's say the the
you know the thinking that is data
mining unbiased and of course the you
know these methods that i'm showing here
for calculation of graphs between
molecules from
high dimensional this is from high
dimensional single-cell genomics data or
manifold projection you know which is
this is a universal manifold uh
approximate projection here that i'm
showing on the right hand side these are
these are unbiased but in a way in in
doing these calculations we are we have
as as as the scientists
you know that we we have a sort of a
certain hypothesis or a certain
mental uh framework
that that drives us to actually
um
simplify and project the data in this
way even if the computational methods
are unbiased
that's getting a little theoretical and
philosophical but for instance what i'm
showing here is a graph calculated
through the correlation of transcription
factors and as such it's completely
unbiased that's a completely
hypothesis-free method
but actually
my hypothesis you know i have a sort of
hypothesis that i haven't articulated
here and that is that the subset of
genes that i'm showing here are
transcriptional regulators they're they
are the class of genes that switch other
genes on and off
and so the reason that we did this this
analysis
was that our hypothesis is that these
are the key regulatory factors that
determine these cell states and that's
why we're calculating the correlation
between expression between you know
um right and then you have to wrap it
this way so i think there's always a
sort of yin and yang and a
um
um
uh uh
you know data mining there's always a
there isn't um a contradiction between
the hype the hypothesis driven
mechanistic
modeling and the
unbiased quote unquote data science kind
of approach because actually they're not
so they're not completely different
worlds because actually there's often a
hypothesis or a sort of framework that
you start from even if that ends up you
know surprising and it's not correct and
you discover new things using the
unbiased machine learning or data mining
tools does that make sense yeah thanks
um
so
[Music]
so that really your question really
comes back to this this
sort of supposed dichotomy between the
modelers um who do mechanistic modeling
and the data miners and and you know are
they completely different you know
coming from completely different ends of
the world no they're not actually you
know both of them are scientists who you
know start from certain hypotheses
yes that the data mining approach can
seem completely hypothesis free and
unbiased but um
actually it you know you always start
from from a certain way of analyzing the
data which in itself implies a
hypothesis you then discover components
which in turn can enter the mechanistic
models and so on so at the end of the
day there's really a productive
symbiosis between these different
approaches within the domain of
theoretical and computational biology
and and of course
in in
molecular and cellular biology
we are
we are in a luxurious situation where we
can actually interrogate the systems
experimentally that we're studying
so we're not in a in a operating in a
domain like
climate change and climate modeling
where we can't tinker with one variable
one factor and see what the outcome is
of doing that perturbation or let's say
the cosmos you know that of course my
friend prio works in where you know it's
very difficult to eliminate one planet
or something like that and see what
change it is in biology that's not the
case we can actually do experiments and
so um
it's it's you know and that in a way
um that means that the modeling is has
always been
um part of the
or the the the theoretical and
computational approaches and modeling
and inference have always been part of
biology to some extent and one one
example is genetics and what i'm showing
here is is gregor mendel
uh the the the monk who observed the um
the peas and the variation in in color
size and shape and flowers and so on of
the peas
according to their inheritance
and and from the the patterns that he
observed in terms of um
the the offspring's features he inferred
that there must be the existence of
inherited factors that came to be known
as genes
and so this the the earliest genetics
experiments that are relating changes
to uh genetic crosses
you know are making an inference it's
it's it's uh the the the stroke of
genius that he did was to make this
inference that there are factors that
are inheriting these features
well what i also mentioned is that that
some you know in cell biology and this
is a case of developmental biology so
embryonic development
um there are there are other kinds of
perturbations so that so the genetic
perturbations is basically variation
that's the perturbation
um in here in developmental biology it's
basically taking a bunch of cells or a
tissue
section
and transplanting it into another embryo
and showing that you can
control axis formation through that that
region called the the organizer that
that region of tissue that acts
on on a donor tissue
on a host tissue
the host tissue takes on the features of
the donor tissue
and so that kind of um
that's another kind of perturbation the
third kind of more modern
uh getting towards more high throughput
experiments in genetics
is is is exemplified by this classic
experiment by muslim folhard and bishops
where they did
chemical perturbations
in drosophila embryos to uncover the
genes that control the patterning of the
embryo where you get these
beautiful stripe like patterns that are
controlled through
a hierarchical set of genes that
determine the polarity the gaps and the
the smaller stripes and and ultimately
these these iconic homeotic genes that
control the anterior posterior axis so
it's and and this was through through
systematic chemical mutagenesis and
observation
um by insulin for heart and we shall so
we have these um
the genetics basically and perturbation
experiments
um and we also have what's more the the
molecular and biochemical level of
experiments
in terms of individual molecules and
what i want to use
to exemplify this here
where where inference
plays a role at multiple different
levels is making molecular models so
making
models of the three-dimensional
structure of molecules and of course the
the legendary example is double helix
um where you had
uh two different approaches to to tackle
that on the one hand
the um the careful crystallographic
experimental approach pursued by the
group in london um and the franklin and
gosling paper
that that
publishes the the x-ray diffraction
pattern of crystals
of um
of uh dioxy ribonucleic acid and then of
course the double helix is inferred
computationally from the diffraction
pattern and that in itself is a kind of
inference in the sense that you're
calculating or inferring
what the three-dimensional structure of
the atoms must be
from the x-ray diffraction pattern
measurements
so there you can see that the
experimental measurement really relies
on a computation it's not like gregor
mendel's
piece where he's simply looking at the
color with his eyes
here in order to interpret this very
complex data this x-ray diffraction
pattern and and
um
then sort of predict
the double helical structure from this
pattern what's required is is um
computations you know that um
[Music]
that require computer basically
and um
on the other hand then then watson crick
of course used a combination of
different pieces of evidence
to build the model in a more in a more
conventional way with
actual physical models by using the
information from the diffraction pattern
and the step the distance between the
steps in the rungs of the ladder the
base pairs in the dna double helix
combined with chemical information about
the complementary amounts of
a t and g and c
and um and a few other pieces of
evidence and and then they they stitch
together these orthogonal
pieces of evidence to come up with a
double helical model so there are two
different types of inference here one is
the calculation from an experimental
measurement and the other is basically
putting together different pieces of
experimental data but the the point that
i wouldn't want to bring across here is
that
the experimental data was key to make
the models
and at the same time
the the model had to be validated by
experimental data so it's
this molecular structure prediction
which i'll also talk about later later
is is um is very closely intertwined
with
with the the observations from
experiments being coupled with different
types of inference computational and and
and more um intellectual sort of
modeling
and this challenge of predicting protein
structure and we've you know priya just
just before the talk raised the question
of alpha fold which of course has been
um you know very widely publicized as
this deep learning
approach for systematic structure
prediction
um this has been a challenge basically
from from when the first protein
sequences were were sequenced using
using sort of sun or sangro sequencing
um
um
and um
um you know the the simple little
sequence of insulin for instance had to
wait for
for for many years until uh dorothy
profit hodgkin solved the crystal
structure and so this because of the
the the powerful information that's
inherent in these molecular structures
you just saw the double helix which is a
very clear one because
the the um
that basically then immediately gave the
clue
that the genetic code consists of this
sequence of letters a t g and c
for the proteins which consist of a 20
letter alphabet it's a it's perhaps a
bit more difficult to see
what's so important about knowing these
molecular structures but basically
you'll just have to bear with me and
believe me when i say that this
structure also gives a lot of
information about the function of the
protein and and what its interaction
partners could be and and and so on and
so forth and so this exercise in
critical in protein structure prediction
which has been
um
uh you know a competition in the
community on an annual basis just to
assess or benchmark what the best
structural prediction methods are it's
been going on for for many many for you
know
14 or more iterations
um has in a way culminated in this deep
learning and the reason for that is that
this approach
um
can now at this juncture in our history
draw on such rich experimental data sets
where they are on the order of hundreds
of thousands of individual protein
structures that the rules for for making
these protein structures can now be
learned in an automatic way and that
wasn't wasn't possible in the early days
when there was much less data but there
are many areas of biology for which
that's true
so the protein data bank is the
repository of crystal structures the
three-dimensional atomic coordinates of
molecules proteins like i just showed
you and that's been going on for 50
years now and it's this incredible big
data resource what i'm showing here are
other
um databases in biology the the the
protein sequences and uniprot
genes and genomes in ensembl and then
down at the bottom two um some more
functional genomics um
at databases that i'm involved with the
human cells data portal and the ebi
single cell expression atlas
that are um
portals for
the the single cell genomics data the
the in particular the gene expression
data at the level of single cells which
is being possible
um through through a resolution
revolution genomics that allows us to
measure the expression of single cells
that come to you later in my talk and
this is
the uniprot what is that
uniprot is the um protein sequence
database so the amino acid sequences of
proteins
yeah so my point here was really that
there are a lot of databases now that
provide the substrate
for um
data mining and biology and this is is
really
you know has has is a development that's
gone on over decades but it's really
accelerated over the past few years that
we're now in the era of big data and
biology
and and that's there's absolutely no
question about that it's it's um you
know an exponential increase in data
that's that's happening at the moment
and there are a range of theoretical
numerical approaches that aid inference
and i've said on the one hand there's
modeling there are also in silico
simulations and silicon representations
of systems where you can perturb systems
completely theoretically
um and so so in contrast to these
modeling and simulation approaches there
are data science approaches
and and some of these are when the data
on its own is self-evident like in to
gregor mendel but there are there are
also these larger scale approaches
and um
and yeah these these for alpha thought
it's the structures and um
with these big data approaches now the
the methods are really statistical
computational machine learning and ai as
i've mentioned
um so so
uh you know given that
there is this this very big and
important field of um computational
biology in molecular biology
so there there can be a situation where
this field you know which which wasn't
you know a traditional part of biology
this field of computational biology and
using big data to you know analyze and
and predict
biological
structures biological interactions
molecular interactions and so on um has
meant that some experimentalists might
view the the theoretical component of
molecular biology with suspicion
okay and i'm going to pick up right here
and dive into the main meat of my talk
which is going to be three elements
um one is
uh talking about predicting pathways of
protein complex assembly which is in
that area of predicting molecular
structure
the second is predicting cell types
using single cell genomics data
and the third is the human cell atlas
and using human cellulose data to
predict cell communication and infection
by covert 19 sars cuff 2. so if you
think about the inside of a cell
and the reason why it's important to
predict how protein complexes assemble
this is a molecular stimulation of the
inside of a bacterium and you can see
that essentially it's a it's a very very
crowded place all these proteins and
protein nucleic acid complexes are
multi-molecular complexes that are
rubbing up against each other in a sort
of gel like very very compact
environment where there's hardly there
are hardly any water molecules between
them although they are in
uh aqueous solution
and so
understanding how these large
multi-subunit components these globules
that you can see in the interior of the
cell assemble and how they find their
their partners is is a really
fundamental question in biology that
kind of goes beyond those individual
components that are predicted by alpha
fold to the next level of these
molecular assemblies and that's an area
that i worked on for for
over a dozen years
and
where we're using the big data from
molecular structures and so the the what
we're looking at are proteins the amino
acid sequences and they're really the
output of genes so genes are encoded
levels of dna
they're they're transcribed into
messenger rna which is the the messenger
molecule the intermediate level of
information that we'll come back onto
later and that's then translated into
the protein level this amino acid level
and the question that we're asking in
this work is how do protein complexes
assemble and can we predict these
assembly pathways and so what we needed
to have in the first place is um a big
data set
um that we could we could build our
models from
and that um
we
we built that data set from
over tens of thousands of crystal
structures that were available at the
time when we started this work which was
in the early 2000s actually and we
published this 3d complex database in
2004 so we made our own database that
provide where we we modeled protein
complexes that we first of all predicted
to be in their physiological
confirmation as graphs of the individual
amino acid sequences where the edges
that are shown here between the graphs
are the physical interfaces of the
interacting protein subunits and so this
then allowed us to use graph theory as a
as a theoretical basis
for
relating complexes for matching them to
each other from finding
sub sub components of these graphs that
are um connected to each other
and if
what's important to understand the basis
of this is that
um
over half of all protein complexes are
assemblies of multiple subunits of the
same type they're exactly they're called
homomers they're basically repeats of
the same subunit and they can be related
to each other through um axes of
rotation and um
and and and
and and they can be
uh twofold as you can see here in a in a
dihedral symmetry where there's a
two-fold axis of rotation or they can be
cyclic which can have any number of uh
uh uh
elements around the the circles or in
this doughnut trade we've got four here
but there could be six seven eight and
so on
and then all homomeric complexes because
their closed symmetries consist of uh
combinations of these dihedral two-fold
axes of rotation and and the larger
cyclic axis of rotation and the
important difference between these is
that in a in in this kind of flat
um doughnut shaped sort of repetitive
structure with a cyclic axis of rotation
you've got the the head of one subunit
connecting to the tail of the next the
head of one's the tail of the next and
so on and so this interface consists of
two different surfaces whereas in the
cyclic
uh case in this dihedral axis of
rotation the two-fold axis it's actually
the exact same interface it's two heads
that are contacting each other it's
exactly the same surface that's mirrored
or that's used
not mirrored but that's used within this
dimeric protein structure
and so that that basically means that
there's a different evolutionary there
are different evolutionary pathways and
pressures that make these different
um
symmetries of protein complexes
and the the very simplest as i said
to build something either in evolution
or assembling inside a cell would be for
a single protein subunit to stick to
itself so it encounters another copy of
itself and it sticks to itself through a
dihedral axis two-fold axis of rotation
where um it's like a handshake it's like
you shaking your neighbor's hand your
right hand it's the palm of your hand is
contacting the palm of their hand so
it's exactly the same surface sticking
to itself it's too different it's a
handshake kind of symmetry with a single
two-fold axis of rotation and what that
means in evolution is that if there's
one mutation let's say in the fingers of
your hand that increase the affinity or
stickiness
for the other hand in the handshake then
that mutation will count twice and will
increase the stickiness of the two hands
twice because you have that symmetry
now in the in the other um and here you
can you can have that process occurring
again and another set of two-fold axes
of rotation to make a dimer of dimers in
other words to form this tetramer so
once you've got the dimer the two dimers
can interact with each other and form
the tetramer again with these uh
interfaces that are reusing the same
surface
and a different evolutionary or even
kinetic kind of assembly scenario in the
cell is that three subunits encounter
each other and form a triangular
uh uh here um
interactions that are occurring within
the same plane with a single axis of
rotation down the middle in a in a
cyclic manner and here what we need is
really as i said for the head of one
subunit to interact with the um with the
bottom of the other subunit uh and and
and for this to occur for all three
subunits and what you what what one
mutation would therefore count three
times within
um
within amongst those three subunits and
so you get a weaker slower kind of
increase of the affinity for the three
subunits so one mutation would kind of
uh weakly increase the affinity across
all three interfaces in the same way the
same would go
for me for for four subunits or five
subunits um and this series can kind of
increase in the same way so you see
you're kind of building up these rings
and a single mutation would slowly
increase the affinity across the whole
ring across all the different interfaces
at the same time
now building up these these um stacks of
rings can occur by either
the hexamer over here with the dihedral
threefold symmetry can either form
through a trimeric
uh trimerization of the dimers so it can
come through this three dimer sticking
to each other the optimal can be four
dimers
um the the decamer can be five and so on
um or alternatively we have this these
other pathways where trimer can stack to
form a hexamer tetramorph and stack to
form an optimum and so on so you can get
to these there are two different paths
to get to for instance the hexamer one
is from the monomer to the dimer to the
hexamer the other was from the monomer
to the trimmer to the hexamer and these
different
intermediate states
um can be intermediates both in
evolution or in the kinetic assembly in
in a cell in a biochemical sense and
what we that's what we showed in this
work and this was a paper that kind of
synthesizes these ideas but the builds
on on several other theoretical and
computational analyses
and um what we showed here was the key
principle that these pathways
are are reflected in evolution in the
sense that you find
monomers related to dimers and tetramers
but also trimers related to dimers and
hexamers but all the the pathways that
are that are not connected for instance
a tetramer is is never or only very very
very rarely connected to a hexamer a
trimer is very very rarely connected to
a tetramer and so on so the arrows in
green and red that you're seeing here
are really the main transitions that we
see and that holds both for the
evolutionary pathways and for assembly
pathways and we think that the reasons
that these
principles of evolution assembly of
protein complexes are mirrored is that
it's um it's the size of the interfaces
that really determine
um the the intermediate
forms that are conserved in evolution
and also the intermediates that are
fastest that are formed fastest
kinetically and so in in a in a living
cell and so what that means is that for
instance in the if you had the trim or
as the intermediate to the hexamer then
these interfaces would be larger would
have a higher affinity to each other
would be more stable or if it were the
dime or that's the intermediate for the
hexamer it would be that dimeric
interface that's larger than the
trimeric interface and that was really
the insight in this paper that comes
through a large data mining exercise and
we expanded this concept for heteromeric
complexes and these are complexes that
consist of of subunits of different
types so here you'd have a an octamor
that consists of two subtypes of the
yellow soybeans two of the red tools the
green two of the blue and if these if
these assembled in a random manner you
know you'd still be there in the middle
of the night trying to find the correct
order for these jigsaw pieces to come
together whereas if there's an ordered
assembly where the blue and the red
always form together first and then the
yellow and then the green then you've
got a sort of click click click ikea
kind of assembly and and it's very rapid
and efficient and there are no um
misassemblies or
um
aggregates that are sticky aggregates
that form erroneously inside the cell
and so it's really the speed and the
efficiency of that assembly that's
driving that we show that these
heteromeric assemblies uh also
um are reflected in the in the con
evolutionary conservation and in this
case what we're using is the the
principle of gene fusion and fission
because of course
protein subunits that are that are fused
within the same gene
and that that are uh they're part of the
same polypeptide chain will will be
covalently linked and will be directly
um therefore also
um
kinetically
uh the most efficient subunits to form
interfaces first and and indeed what we
show is that
the the genetic
organization of protein subunits
reflects their assembly order and um
and then these predictions that are
based on a combination of protein
structure they're based on gene gene
structure in the in the two-dimensional
genome sequence of organisms
were verified experimentally through a
beautiful collaboration that we had with
carol robinson's group carl robinson as
a physical chemist was one of the
inventors of macromolecular mass
spectrometry where you measure the mass
of intact protein complexes and through
collaboration with her and
based on the
protein expressed proteins from from
many generous collaborators who gave the
reagents
um we showed that in in in vitro in
uh biochemical experiments our pathway
predictions were
were accurate kind of um
in the vast majority of place of cases
and so overall this body of work we're
showing that protein assembly pathways
just like protein folding itself is an
order process it's fast it's spontaneous
and it's predictable and it's also
conserved in evolution and these
predictions are validated through these
physical chemistry experiments and so
you can think of um
that proteins the amino acid sequence
doesn't only encode the structure it
also encodes assembly instructions you
can think of it as a set of building
blocks where we've got
two building blocks and we've got
the instruction is that the red
interface always binds to the blue
interface g is neutral and exposed to
the solvent and that set of simple
instructions for these building blocks
would encode this cross structure you've
got the red connecting to four blues and
it makes this structure in a way protein
complexes are kind of like that and we
can encode those using graph theory and
complexity theory
this was a fantastic collaboration with
sebastian honored
by collaborating the physics department
and we show here that we can develop a
sort of shorthand for what the the
individual protein subunits are and what
interfaces they will form with their
partner so we've got gray and white here
um
a interacts with d with uh
c interacts with d
and and um and that basically forms this
this square structure on the other hand
if we've got gray and white but c
interacts with b
um
and a with a will get this linear
structure
and with equal numbers of building
blocks that that are the the general
rule in nature
you you
take those those um
principles into account and you end up
calculating what what we describe as a
periodic table of protein complexes and
the power of the periodic table of the
elements just is is similar in a way to
this periodic table of protein complexes
because the the principles of atoms and
electrons in the case of the periodic
table predict features of the elements
here principles of
evolution and assembly of subunits
predict
structures that are of of the individual
elements here in terms of the number of
repeats and the number of subunits of of
cells in this matrix that are not that
are that were not filled in by
experiments but that we are able to fill
in
computationally and those predictions
then were also verified by later
releases of the protein data bank
we also showed why
um
[Music]
why
um
how how this is kind of accommodated in
the in the translation of proteins and
what you're seeing here is a simulation
of two elements of the ribosome this is
from adrian alcock from iowa in
collaboration with my group and this
simulation this molecular simulation
shows two polypeptide chains coming out
of two adjacent ribosomes sitting on a
messenger rna and what that tells us is
that the
the the n-terminus that comes out of the
ribosomes first so the this beginning of
the of the trains is likely to also
interact um
with it is likely to also interact first
and that kind of um
uh that sort of in vivo
um
you know taking into account these in
vivo kinetics
of co-translational assembly
um
uh also gives us much more more detailed
information about the constraints on
making homomeric proteins and that the
the
the parts of the amino acid chains that
come come out first
are are interacting with each other um
before the other parts assemble and so
that that's a kind of more detailed
level of the principle of of how these
uh polypeptide trans assembly in in
terms of homomeric relationships where
exactly the same
copies of exactly the same protein are
interacting with themselves with
with more copies of themselves
so in summary we've used evolutionary
relationships and principles of protein
biophysics to predict assembly pathways
there are inferences from thousands of
protein structures and and evolutionary
sequence relationships between proteins
as well as gene structure
and and our predictions were were
experimentally validated both by
macromolecular mass by trauma
mass spectrometry and also by
by structures of proteins and so that's
really the lesson about predicting
protein complex assembly pathways and
you can see from this little story that
it was a synergistic
exercise basically that involved
bioinformatics of at the structural
level bioinformatics the sequence level
um
simulations like the molecular
stimulation that you just saw of the
ribosome making these proteins and
coming out of the
the ribosomes um coupled with
physical chemistry micromolecular mass
spectrometry experiments
and and also by physical experiments
that i didn't show
so there's really you know this this
science is really uh
a collaborative
effort between um different disciplines
and and
different types of scientists working
together to try to
um
discover the truth essentially
in the second part of my talk i'm going
to shift gears and and go on to
predicting a completely different
building block of life and that is the
cell
and um
the the the basis of this is really the
um
the evolution of genomics from
sequencing dna as in the human genome
project to sequencing rna
which
gives us a molecular fingerprint of
cells in terms of the subset of rna
that's inside each single cell and it's
that subset of messenger rna that tells
us about the the molecular features of
the cell and in terms of what proteins
would also be expressed inside that cell
and of course the cell is basically the
a fundamental unit of life it's a
component of tissues and the tissues in
our body
are are are the the individual
microenvironments of organs so the nose
here upper respiratory system lungs and
the lower respiratory system the thymus
which is where t cells are made the
heart and so on each one consists of
many different types of cells
and um
conventional rna sequencing sort of
conventional bulk genomics
used to require thousands and thousands
of cells to be mashed up together before
the the nucleic acid was extracted and
put on the sequencer
over the past
over
almost 15 years um the the genomics has
has undergone a so-called resolution
revolution where we're now able to
sequence the nucleic acid content from
each individual cell in a sample and
that's called single cell genomics and
it's that has really opened up
um the ability to interrogate single
cells almost more powerfully than using
a microscope because what we can do is
isolate individual cells either in well
plates or using microfluidic robotics
and then
extract or or
label the the messenger rna the
comprehensive nucleic acid content of
each single cell and sequence that and
then analyze the vast data sets that
tell us the true the genes that are
active in single cells and this has been
a series of technological innovations
that's gone on from 2009 to date really
with many different types of isolation
technologies genomics protocols and
computational methods that have evolved
a pace and that now individual
experiments routinely encompass on the
order of a million cells and of course
that advance in technology has been you
know absolutely revolutionary for for
biology i think it's it's it's it's not
kind of um
an underestimate to say that and it's
also been coupled kind of um
slightly behind single cell genomics
with a spatial genomics revolution which
allows us to measure nucleic acid
content of tissue sections where the
cells are actually in their native
tissue context so you're you're then
taking a slice of a tissue
like a mouse brain that's shown here and
what we see here is the expression of
six genes each in a different spatial
region and this is from
members of my group together with omar
biorector's group and oliver schnegler's
group that have developed
a for a statistical probabilistic
inference framework for mapping
individual cells
to spatial genomics data and
um from the single cell trinomics data
one of the key
kind of data mining exercises is to
infer cell types
and the way that the the way we do that
is using a set of algorithms called
clustering
which is you know encompasses a vast
array of different
approaches but essentially
um what the what the exercise entails is
finding individual data points that are
similar to each other and then grouping
them and
what you're seeing here
are um
data sets from from gut embryonic and
fetal on the left pediatric on the right
so they're intestinal samples
and each each little spot on this
two-dimensional projection consists of a
single cell
and that that data point encompasses in
and of itself thousands and thousands of
gene expression levels so it's a vast
matrix of hundreds of thousands of cells
each with thousands of thousands of
genes expressed and the total number of
genes of course in our human genome is
somewhere between 25 and 30 000
depending on how you count and so this
matrix that we're clustering consists of
hundreds of thousands of cells um
multiplied you know across 25 25 000
genes roughly and then the exercises to
cluster those data points that are
similar with each other and and um are
and that that's basically then our
interpretation
of of the cell types
that are present in the data set and you
can see here that interpretation is a
combination of clustering and data
mining but also
kind of uh that like priya was asking in
the beginning there is intellectual
input there are hypotheses there is
external data that we're putting into
the interpretation and they're they're
uh the cell types are are shown in
different colors and annotated and
different things so you see immune cells
they're kind of lumped together
neurons of the the gut we have a kind of
brain that surrounds our gut
interestingly they're labeled in yellow
um
we've got smooth muscle that's that's
around the gut and that's responsible
for moving material through the gut and
not shown in brown
and um the actual and parasites that are
absorbing material inside the gut are
all shown in
um
in the blue colors here and so they're
different they're different cell types
that are shown in different colors for
the different clusters based on the
similarity in there in their expression
profiles
and so again how the cell clustering
works is that we're grouping cells with
similar expression patterns
in a way it's a hypothesis free grouping
it's a data mining grouping on the one
hand on the other hand as i said there
is in in the final interpretation of the
data there's often external information
that enters it so there's a kind of
intellectual puzzle where the scientist
is also putting in data
this is um
high dimensional data different
clustering algorithms can indeed produce
different results
so how do we know what result to use and
what's the best algorithm one of the
tests for this is is theoretical that is
self consistency and our single cell
clustering assessment framework is is
attempting to do exactly that sorry this
should be two season one a
um
slight slight error here so um and and
what we're doing here is a cross
validation so a simulation or assessment
of
uh the clustering results by testing
whether the two clusters can actually
model
uh and and discover each other
with a with a using logistical rational
machine learning method or whether they
are sufficiently distinct that they
don't cross-match to each other when we
model
their
properties in terms of their weighted
levels of gene expression
and so
there's basically ways of assessing the
different clustering algorithms from a
theoretical and computational point of
view and then there's of course also
ways of assessing the results from from
clustering algorithms experimentally or
using external data from the literature
um
in in any case so the the print we've
we've
predicted cell types here for 20 tissues
in the human body this is almost a
million data points very recently it's
very exciting you know to be able to be
at this juncture where we have data that
covers
a representative set of tissues from the
whole body it's not the entire body but
it's maybe half of the tissues in our
body you know we're getting very close
and it's a very exciting time now for
the community
and um
as i said this is an an automatic you
know a million cells it's not something
that you can do by hand greg or mendel
or watson crick you know those kinds of
approaches are not going to work we need
to do this by machine learning and we
use a supervised or semi-supervised
approach
um so that we can then make these models
of cell types which allow us to transfer
labels from the known data sets to new
data sets and in general of course you
know we're at the point where
um
we're somewhere in between these these
regimes when you're when you have little
data you require a lot of knowledge and
the more data that you have the less
knowledge you really need to interpret
it because um
you're kind of crystallizing
you have enough data sort so crystallize
very
very accurately basically the the for
instance the clusters in your data sets
or the um
the the
the the protein structures in your alpha
phil predictions and this is from carl
hendrick eck who's a colleague of neil
henderson um neil lawrence in the
uh in the computer science department in
cambridge i think it summarizes
uh the the kind of development of single
cell genomics and and computational
biology in this area of cell type
annotation uh really nicely
so we are we're getting to the era of
large scale single cell expression data
sets
where we can we can we don't need so
much model selection and tuning anymore
and so the motivation is um
where we can make classifiers that that
um
that that can automate the annotation
we want we we compiled this data for
many many data sets 19 different data
sets
from different regions of the body
and asked whether their tissue-specific
cell states whether there are cell
states that are shared across tissues
there are many really exciting questions
that we can now
uh use this data set for to interrogate
um uh the the the cells from across the
human body we we made um
um
uh so they they cluster into roughly 100
different cell types and there are
subdivisions of 10 broad cell types and
just to sort of give you an overview of
the workflow you have to basically
integrate the data sets harmonize
assemble sort of clean the data do
initial training
model the data
and then and then you can um
feed into unannotated new data and
interrogate it with the reference model
and that can in turn then re-enter
the pipeline and and contribute to to
the training data in itself and so you
can go through a kind of iterative
process where you expand your models
with more and more data
uh systematically and so basically the
take home from this is that we are
entering the area of big data in single
cell genomics just the way we we did in
protein structures in the previous
section of the talk or in the alpha fold
and the biological interpretation of
that data just needs computational
inference because it's it's just so vast
and the computational tools in
bioinformatics on the other hand need to
keep pace with the experimental
technology so there's a kind of to and
fro and a symbiosis between the theory
and the computation
i'm coming to the last part of the talk
now um and and um where i'm going to
discuss uh prediction of cell
communication how cells talk to each
other how they communicate with each
other and how we can predict which cells
get infected using human cell atlas data
so the human cell atlas is an
international consortium with the
mission of creating comprehensive
reference map of cells
using single cell genomics coupled with
spatial data and interpreted with
computational methods and it's you can
think of it as a google maps of the
human body where we're using this new
cutting edge high resolution
technologies to get from the kind of
coarse grained view of the human body to
the google street maps view
and we we um we founded this about five
years ago this is this my co-founder my
partner in crime in this endeavor as a
beef regev and we've now grown to a
community of about 2 000 members across
you know really across the globe 77
countries across the world this is a
grassroots bottom-up scientist-led
initiative and we are organized into
working groups and biological networks
that focus on the different organs and
tissues in the body as well as human
development organoids and genetic
genetic diversity
and one of the first my first um project
on
human cells and tissues as opposed to
mouse or or other model systems
was the the placenta
and what we set out to do in um from
about
2015 2016 was to map this organ that's a
transient organ that's at the interface
between the mother and the fetus sort of
in the in the inside of the womb
and it's it's of course only present for
nine months of your life but it's
absolutely crucial and essential to your
development for those nine months and
you wouldn't be here without this organ
and and it's relatively poorly
understood because it's
uh the human is very different from
mouse and even different from from the
most closely related non-human primates
the chimpanzees
um
it's shown here in red
and and of course the the really
intriguing conundrum to me here
was that there's a mystery
um about how the maternal immune system
tolerates the paternal antigen so of
course our immune systems are tuned to
reject anything that's non-self
and and that's really the basis of our
health and our homeostasis and yet in in
when we're pregnant we are tolerating uh
something that's non-self that has
antigens or proteins that come from the
father and so how is that actually
possible
and what we set out to do therefore was
to study this
tissue by dissociation sorting cells
single cell genomics using two different
technologies microfluidic droplets and
well plates
uh studied robotically and then
computationally clustered the cells and
you can see here we studied both the
decidual which is the the uterus or
endometrium the placenta which is the so
the uterus is the maternal side the
placentas the fetal side and the
maternal blood in order to distinguish
cells that were
from the maternal blood and and this
gave us a uh the cell phone book i'll
call it which means what are the
individual cellular components of both
the the maternal side and the fetal side
and you can see here there are immune
cells and k cells t cells
there are glandular epithelial cells
that do the secretions to support the
the fetus there are fibroblasts which
are kind of um structural components of
the uterus
and um
it's really through through the
statistical inference that we're able to
find all these cell types but what we
really wanted to understand was how does
this immunological tolerance take place
and to understand that what we need to
also
dig into is how the cells are talking to
each other we call this cell phone a
statistical inference system for
deciphering cellular interactions
through the the receptor ligand
complexes so this links to the protein
complex assembly that i talked about in
the first part of the talk
and um
and how those
protein complexes on the surfaces of
adjacent cells are mediating the the
interactions between cells so this is a
a kind of uh uh interaction that's at a
higher level than the proteins it's at
the level of the individual cells we
developed a statistical inference
framework to look for receptor ligand
interactions between cell types between
single cell clusters that are specific
to those cell types so they're not
ubiquitous these aren't molecules that
are expressed everywhere they're
molecules that are specifically
complementary between individual cell
types and that allowed us to decipher
the cells from the placental side the
fetal side that you can see up here
where you've got the the placental
trophoblast cells you've got placental
immune cells blood vessels fibroblasts
the maternal blood is pushing around
here you've got extra virus trophoblasts
which are the invading the
the uterus the maternal blood vessels
the maternal glands maternal immune
cells and there are a lot of
interactions that are taking place that
that guarantee that immunological
tolerance that i mentioned earlier and
that we discovered in this work
and and so this is really a kind of
flavor of a cell atlas exercise it's one
of the first organs that was mapped in
this way we mapped all different regions
of the placenta and to get a
comprehensive overview
and um
um and and this we published this work
in 2018 and then of course over the
intervening years there are a lot of uh
um
tissue and organ data sets
that that became available and and there
are those 20 tissues in almost a million
cells that i mentioned earlier in that
integrated data set and so when the
pandemic hit in early 2020 we became
aware that there was this virus
circulating what we leveraged was the
the human cell atlas data and also the
humans allowed the scientific community
to understand covet 19 and that that
endeavors really continued but i want to
tell you this story from the very early
days of the pandemic where we mapped the
viral entry receptors from the human
cell atlas data so we asked in all of
this single cell genomics data from
around the body where are the viral
entry receptors expressed that could
welcome the virus into the cells because
of course the virus is docking onto the
surface of cells and so we're simply
asking can we predict
where the virus is entering in the
healthy human
uh cell atlas data
and we we assemble data from all around
the body you can see the different
tissues here and then mapped where is t2
is expressed and i'm going to focus very
briefly on the barrier tissues where the
healthy reference data is probably most
useful and is telling us where the virus
can hit and of course the nose is one of
the main ones where we have the the
nasal passages where you've got
inhalation of of aerosol droplets and
indeed here we find epithelial cells
goblet and ciliated cells that have high
expression levels for ace two
intercourse two so we pointed towards
those specific cells
as being potential viral entry points
and the lower airways the bronchi you've
got club and ciliated
sorry my internet disconnected yeah no
worries yeah
so we have found cells in the eye
and um
in the in the gut epithelium and
parasites
and also in the placenta which i just
talked about
where we hypothesize that there are
cells that can tran that can be
responsible for the vertical
transmission from the maternal to the
fetal side now while this is rare what
this data shows is that there's a
potential pathway of transmission
these were all predictions about where
the virus could enter we were trying to
get to
truth and information and insights into
this this
infection as quickly as possible using
cell atlas data and what's really
exciting is that since then we published
that work last year it's been cited
um about 1300 times it got a lot of
attention also from from the public
health point of view
um what's really exciting is that those
predictions have largely come true from
experimental data where we can see for
instance from nasal swabs that we can
read
next generation sequencing reads mrna of
the virus inside individual cells in the
nasal epithelium i should also say that
in the mouth which i haven't discussed
we predict
um
salivary gland ductal cells
in the in the top of the salivary glands
in the ducts where the virus could enter
and indeed in these microscopy images we
can see that the virus is indeed sitting
inside those cells and we published that
this year so for ace ace2 and the sars
co2 virus the correlation with the
receptor does indeed reflect the
infection
um in the infected cells and so that's
really the last part of my story i've
told you about protein complex assembly
pathways and data mining from protein
structures inferences from single cell
genomics to predict cell types and cell
states through the clustering predicting
cell communication the maternal fetal
interface and viral entry
into cells through the cell surface
receptors and so i'd like to summarize
basically the high level what this is
telling us about correlation causation
is that in the protein complex assembly
these data mining approaches for for
linking evolution assembly
the correlation was was experimentally
validated using physical chemistry mass
spectrometry and other methods
um in single cell genomics
the the the cell typist models really
rely on
the data is of such a scale that the
interpretation really relies on machine
learning and computational tools like
clustering
and for this human cell atlas what i
told you about the the cell cell
interactions in the placenta and the
covalent infected cells is that these
correlations
are now coming true based on on
orthogonal experimental measurements and
later experimental data and with that
i'd like to thank you and take any
questions
um
thank you so much sarah first of all for
your enormous patience through
the disruptions for today what an
exciting set of uh experiments and
conceptual model building that
you and collaborators have been
uh working on and truly
interdisciplinary so thank you so much
for allowing us a glimpse into the this
world and the uh and the results
um so i think we have um we have a
couple of questions we
had one from deepti um and the chat
and
her question is how do you account for
heterogeneity of time
what is the time that you are using in
the spatial clustering analysis
so these are all snapshots
essentially um so in the um
[Music]
yeah so the example in the spatial
genomics of the mouse brain for instance
you know that's a snapshot
for at one point in time through a
tissue section
same for the placenta you know it's a
snapshot of a tissue that you're
measuring at one point in time now
within that there are
kind of pseudo-temporal relationships
between cells which i didn't discuss
because you have
cells that are progenitors of other
cells
so you kind of have stem cells that give
rise to other cells
and those relationships i mean inferring
those relationships is another whole
field in and of itself
in actually in some of the gut data that
i mentioned there are stem cells
and differentiated cells within the
epithelial compartment
and um
in in the data projection that i showed
in 2d you can almost see those
relationships where the stem cells are
kind of more at the bottom at the root
of a
of a trajectory and the differentiated
cells are kind of more at the top but we
weren't formally doing that inference
here it just comes out in the in the
manifold projection
yeah
um
thank you if i may well i have a
question so you know one of the
arguments that is always made about
you know um comparing uh disciplinary
approaches
say physics and biology
is that you know in physics we have some
guidance
from conservation laws so you know you
have conservation of energy conservation
of angular momentum and so on
and those really form the bedrock on on
which we build inference models because
these give you constraints
so and the and this question often
arises
are there i mean there are clearly
symmetries do these symmetries similarly
translate into
conservation new conservation laws or
are there just similar sort of you know
entropy and energy i mean are these the
sorts of conservation laws that operate
no i mean that's a great that's a great
question i'd say
so
there are some i mean at one level
biology is physics and so you know in
biophysics
like in the in the macromolecular
assembly you know at some level
this is physics it's biophysics it's
physical chemistry that the laws of
physics apply and of course they apply
to all of biology in that sense but but
when you're dealing with the sort of big
data
sets then you're not in that regime
but there are still like sort of you
know the this central dogma that i
showed which is dna makes rna makes
protein
like that central dogma would still
enter into any
into any of these data mining
assumptions so for instance we are
predicting cell types from the rna but
our kind of unarticulated assumption is
that those
those rna fingerprints will translate
into what what proteins the cell is
expressing so there are some fundamental
truths that everybody
has as part of their kind of a mental
map
when they're doing
you know in when they're doing
biological science but do they do they
uh
do they then become
constraints as well
so
can they can yes
they can
um
and um
yes and and
you know because the central dogma may
not always hold because uh you may have
rna that doesn't make protein you know
and and so that can
um
you know that that correlation may not
hold or that assumption may be
misleading but i would say it's it's the
the exception rather than the wall right
yeah yeah but yeah i get your point
right because i mean i think that is
sort of one of uh the features
when you make inferences in sort of
physical systems
and if you have um
you're looking for these uh unmapped
correlations and when you find them
um you still if if some of them violate
the
conservation of energy for example
then you know that you are probably
missing a variable or there is a hidden
variable
uh that you know you in your infra
inference structure you have uh
overlooked or
uh and so on so
i guess what you're saying is that it's
not yeah i mean there are
so i see what you mean so there are kind
of like sense tracks
um you know like that and and one of
them would be so for instance that um
you know cell types that are
that have developed from different
progenitors or that are completely
different let's say epithelial and
neuronal so the you know the brain and
the epithelial tissues those cell types
should never let's say logistic
regression models machine learning
models should never cross match each
other and so that was kind of the
internal consistency check that i
mentioned where we're looking for
um you know set clusterings that are
separate or that are that are hitting
each other or that are finding each
other there's that kind of thing that
you can use right so it's based on a
sort of developmental
right so i guess that is not true yeah
the so i guess the way this would um
kind of connect to a physics kind of
argument that i was making is that one
constraint would be that you know
these cells cannot transmute into each
other that's a wonderful constraint that
they have they are independent building
blocks that don't transform into each
other
exactly yeah okay exactly great thank
you um any other questions
i just wanted to make a comment on what
you said at the last moment priya about
the cells can't become another cell well
as long as you're not looking at stem
cells right sarah right right yes
i mean i guess
but the progenitors you know let's say
gut
uh you know stem cell wouldn't become a
brain i mean naturally
you know so the the neuronal progenitors
will be different from the the gut
epithelial progenitors
um
i mean that's a kind of reasonable
assumption for any biologist i think
you can force them to do those things in
the dish in a frankensteinian kind of
way but they wouldn't happen naturally
necessarily
right so um i think uh while we wait for
someone else i mean i have i think jenny
is wants to ask a question yeah
okay sorry please go ahead jenny okay
thanks i just tried to be polite
um thanks for the great talk um
concerning priya's question as well i
would like to follow up on this you have
single cells and you try to cluster them
by type
but they are not you do not take into
account the environment of these cells
this comes only when you take into
account the human cell atlas
so would your clustering
types then change by taking into account
the environment of each cell type
where you get different clusters by
taking this
environment into account
i mean so so so in theory you know the
data um
[Music]
like you you shouldn't i mean the the
molecular fingerprint based on the rna
content should should
you know
we think that that should be sufficient
to to
um determine the identity of a cell but
of course if you have additional
information about the environment if you
have let's say a cluster that's large
and very dispersed
and and it and and
you know in in in the 20 000 uh gene
space then you may
you know having the the precise micro uh
anatomical micro environmental niche
information the tissue may tell you oh
you know in the um
in the
in the crypts of the colon there's this
uh let's say intra-epithelial t-cell
type whereas in the villi there's this
entropathial t-cell type and we can now
distinguish them
you know based on very very very subtle
differences within this cluster because
we have the micro environmental
information i mean that's what that's
one of the things that we developed this
uh this method called milo with john
marione's group that basically
distinguishes sort of very subtle
neighborhoods in a k n graph of the
single cell genomics data based on
external information
the kind of metadata parameters that you
can give the
the algorithm
um
so yeah that's a that's a good point
taking into account
um
metadata about location can can resolve
clusters in a more
um
in a more fine-grained way
thanks so you get sub-clusters
yeah and and sub clusters that are
that you couldn't where there wouldn't
be sufficient information based on the
single cell genomics data alone but
using the metadata you then have enough
statistical power and basis to
distinguish them
mm-hmm
thanks
boson
hussain
yeah i have a question more about
prediction towards the future so i'm
curious as i know that the human cell
atlas is in the process of building the
map
of human cells so just like we learned
about the differences between the
sequences of individual human genomes on
the bulk level
where do you see this going in terms of
this single cell level in terms of
different individuals having i don't
know different numbers of cells or cell
types or expression profiles yeah so the
human genetics level for the human cell
atlas is
is is basically coming now for
individual tissues so where it started
off if you remember for the human genome
project the equivalent is sort of
the the next level was kind of you know
population genetics or g wasps and it
starts off with individual genes rather
than the whole human genome and i would
say for the human cells the the
counterpart of that is
genetics of let's say blood or genetics
of
let's say you know
[Music]
small intestinal biopsies where you're
able to gather
uh
samples from hundreds of donors and can
then calculate like you said differences
in abundances of cell types or
differences in
uh patterns of gene expression at the
single cell level
of on on the human genetic scale using
single cell eqtl
or dynamic eqtl inference algorithms
and
and that that's an area that's
developing both on the experimental
level and on the computational level
about what's the best way to do that in
fact we're collaborating with neil
lawrence who's going to join me as a
discussion tomorrow about
uh in terms of algorithms for analyzing
single cell genomics data at the human
genetics level using gaussian processed
light and variable models
so i think that's where it's going yeah
thanks
thanks i guess
we had
i guess um sunny is that you
so i think fred was asking a question
and where uh
i was saying
fred bennett had one one more person
william uh who had uh william
hi
thanks for your talk i really enjoyed it
um i'm not a real scientist i'm a social
scientist so maybe excuse my ignorance
on uh this it sounds kind of coming from
like again on the street to perspective
but uh over the past year and a half
there seems to be certain countries that
elements today are immune that have had
a lot greater chance of uh controlling
spread and transmission of like the
coping bacterium uh virus was wondering
if there's any evidence
in sort of the genomic field of whether
certain populations might be like uh
more genetically adept at overcoming um
kovids and others say like in southeast
asia perhaps some previous exposure to
regional waves of stars has given some
sort of um
advantageous adaptations to um
the bodies dealing uh with this new
virus
so advantageous adaptations
from the viral point of view sorry i
don't quite understand the question
yeah i was wondering i guess what i'm
wondering is if you look at all this
data that you've collected if there's
any indications that
um
your samples from certain populations
and parts of the world
uh
are different in a way that allows um
a better response to viral oh okay no
now i understand what you mean so so the
answer to that is we don't have enough
data to really
so so so so the answer to that is is
there are a couple of different answers
so in this
um
uh gaussian process latent variable
model approach that i mentioned what we
can do is map the associations with
immunity to covin19 onto
both nasal sort of epithelial data and
also onto blood data of populations and
show that the the os1
mutation in this rna processing enzyme
that's part of the
uh the innate immune response against
the virus any that's present in every
single cell in our body
that that um
that there are indeed
sort of genetic variants that lead to a
a higher expression with a certain
splice variant
versus other variants that lead to a
lower expression with a lower splice
variant and that the ones with the
um the mutation
um that leads to the the splicing
truncation has lower expression and and
that may explain the um
the higher propensity to sphere covet 19
of people who have that genetic variant
so essentially we can sort of take the
the association data and interpret it in
terms of expression based on these data
sets that's one thing that we can do
and that's one thing that we that we're
showing in this unpublished work um that
we'll post online soon and then the the
other thing that we can learn by looking
at population data of covert 19
is um
um is is the difference between children
and adults in terms of their innate and
adaptive immune responses and we have a
post on that on a
publication on med archive that i didn't
talk about and what we see there is that
the children have a much stronger innate
immune response and
a more polyclonal adaptive immune
response so children are really
um kind of better poised to get rid of
the virus quickly whereas our our innate
immune response is kind of more sluggish
or adult responses
and the kids are also developing a kind
of t and b cell response from scratch if
you will so they don't rely on their
memory of tnb cells which we do as
adults we rely on our immune memory
and and so we have smaller larger clones
of t and b cells whereas the kids are
seeing these viruses for the first time
and have a much more
uh kind of diverse
um
population of b cells in their response
so that's a kind of
those are the bits of things that we've
learned from this work there's a lot
more to learn
but it's you know we have learned quite
a lot about the innate about immune
responses and different
genetic with people with different
genetic variants kids versus adults and
so on
and and we'll continue to study this
over the coming years because it's you
know
incredibly important i think not just
for covet 19 actually but you know we're
actually learning new things about
virology and immunity overall
so there's a question by fred uh let's
take that question
and
yeah
so fred is asking is there something in
common between the three parts the talk
and i would say the central
um take-home message is really
um the central thing that i wanted to
illustrate as a common thread throughout
all these things is
really the iterative cycle between
having big data in biology
using
statistical computational machine
learning approaches to analyze it and
make predictions
and then going back to the cycle of
experiments to validate those
predictions like i said in biology we
have the the luxury of being able to do
that cycle because we can interrogate
molecular and cellular systems
experimentally it's not like the cosmos
or the climate and really the central
message that i want to get across is
that that's a very powerful
paradigm of iterating from biology to
prediction
with these big data methods and then
back to experiments
you know that that codes across
structural biology it holds across
cellular biology it holds across tissue
biology and virology
it's whatever you whatever you wherever
you look kind of thing yeah and i think
as you mentioned sir this ability to do
controlled experiments
is really key in
validating these predictions
for
the kinds of conceptual computational
models that are being built
so if there are no
further questions
just wait for a minute to see if anyone
raises their hand or
types in the chat uh let's all thank uh
sarah for an excellent talk
thank you everybody for staying here so
late
thank you very much